that is alec baldwin holding the gun
that ultimately killed cinematographer
helena hutchins six months ago welcome
everyone to entertainment tonight it's
just one of the many many hours of
dramatic law enforcement footage
released from the set of rust what you
are about to see is raw emotional and
heartbreaking for the first time we get
a glimpse of the chaos that ensued on
set during the final moments of helena
hutchins life
are you doing okay no i'm not actually
okay
you were in the room when the lady went
to the gun
i turn a [ __ ] the gun goes off
it's supposed to be a cold gun
alec appeared stunned as investigators
arrived on the rus set mr baldwin um
who's the director on scene the guy that
was shot again the guy was shot he also
seemed cooperative i don't know if this
is suspected blood or real blood
police photograph him in costume and
then a detective shares heartbreaking
news about helena's condition the exit
point was on her back
left shoulder blade so
it went it went through
you have no idea how unbelievable this
is and how strange this is
we also see alec facetime his wife
elaria just before he sits down with
detectives i don't want to be a public
person
and you know i'm the one holding the gun
in my hand that everybody was supposed
to have taken care of they always hand
me a cold gun when he has the right to
remain silent so my only question is am
i being charged with something no we're
just interviewing he should just shot up
already
as for the impact of those police tapes
we asked former detective and private
investigator bo dietl they should have
been a lawyers don't just shut up he
shouldn't be doing any interviews
because it could hurt him if he's
charged
alec was also seen in production footage
rehearsing with the revolver how do i
know this is a gun that's the gun we're
also getting our first look at armorer
hannah gutierrez reed after the shooting
i'm the armor
at least i was
the distraught 24 year old is seen with
investigators second guessing her time
on the set i wish i would have checked
it more
obviously she was not that experienced
otherwise this would have happened and
we can see the frenzy that began as soon
as police arrived at the scene
this is a crime scene dozens of crew
members were interviewed who paint a
picture of what happened on set he was
just
he was mortified that's the third time
that
a gun from the armor has gone off
without
at the wrong time the firearms wranglers
have been less than
cautious
children
they're not experienced key rigging grip
johnny zilo told investigators he saw
hannah empty the rounds from the gun
that killed helena he says she was
checking to make sure the remaining
bullets were dummies dummy rounds have a
hole in bb inside that rattles when it
shakes real bullets do not she shook
every one of them but one of them didn't
have a hole drilled in it like the
others that load should not have been in
that gun at the hospital director joel
souza had the discharge bullet removed
from his shoulder for evidence
and asked police about pressing charges
i'd be able to talk to them about
pressing charges
pressing charges
these clips are just a few of the 168
videos released to the public police say
they did so based on public records
requests deidl says that's unusual for
an ongoing investigation it's very
premature to release this and i think
it's now
it can really screw up what the district
attorney is going to do no criminal
charges have been filed against alec
hannah nor anyone involved in the film
however there are at least five lawsuits
pending including helena hutchins family
and last week the production was fined
136 thousand dollars for complete
failure to keep employees safe they cut
some safety protocols and then something
like this happens
you know helena's father told an
australian newspaper that her son
andrews fell silent for two days after
he learned that his mother had passed
away and that's the thing that i think
we need to stay focused on needs all our
prayers cannot even imagine